tonight we are continuing our
reading and study
of Provisions for the day of the great
meeting of the great appointment meaning
the day of judgment and these Provisions
t as taken from the ways and traditions
of the best of servants the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
by the esteemed and late scholar of
Islam
and we had arrived at a
fle which the scholars of Islam use the
word f to
articulate a chapter or sometimes a
sub
chapter right so they will refer to a
book as aab and a f as a as a sub
chapter and a bab as a full chapter but
in this case f here is more similar to a
completely different chapter and usually
it is categorized as such as a different
chapter in the books of F and that
is the chapter on
meaning that an individual forgets
something in their prayer in order for
us to understand this chapter properly
we need to understand the three types of
seu that can occur in a person's prayer
right a lot of understanding F and
Islamic jurisprudence has a lot to do
with a has a lot to do with
understanding the issue properly and
properly
visualizing what the issue that is
being discussed is in its actuality and
this is where the scholars of Islam
mention
that an individual must have a scholar
to teach him an individual must be
instructed traditionally by a
scholar to have take this knowledge
in the traditional sense not just from
books or information and one of the
reasons for that and some of the
scholars of Islam had mentioned of
them
whoever
finds and learns Islamic jpin through
books then this individual will in
ibly make many mistakes the reason for
this is that a lot of what f is is
understanding the actual issue that is
being
discussed that an individual has to
properly visualize what it is that is
being discussed before they can apply
any ruling to it this is where most
mistakes are made most mistakes are made
in
improper visualization
improper understanding of the actual
situation so for example if a person
were to bring you a contract and to ask
you is this contract Oram and there are
stipulations in that contract or
conditions or issues that perhaps
uses particular
terminology that is specific to that
field
whether whatever that field is yet is
generally used in the English language
if an individual were to read that and
understand it not as the people of
that field understand it then they have
improperly understood and visualized the
actual issue so when they try to render
a ruling on that derived from the Quran
derived from the Sunnah of the prophet
sallallah
they will very often times make
horrendous blunders and the reason for
that one of the reasons one of the main
reasons for that is a fundamental
misunderstanding of what the actual
issue being debated
is this is why
becomes kind of
complicated and this is is why the
scholars of Islam often times will
usually go through a process in studying
F you have the most summarized and then
a little bit more you know in books
that they teach their students sum very
summarized and then a little bit more
expounded and then a little bit more and
then the for ofb and then very
extensive and they will study these
things and they're studying the same
issue over and over and over but it's
being said in different ways
and there is a very big important
purpose for that and that is that the
student
must very clearly understand and be
able to visualize the
issue when we are talking about a SE a
SE
SE literally translates to
forgetfulness and forgetfulness in Salah
something that is all of us are prone to
in Salah and outside of Salah
Allah subhanahu wa taala is the only
one described
as not forgetting subhanahu
waala and the prophet
sallam as tells us here he
says he
said indeed I am merely a human being as
you all are human beings and I am hence
prone to forgetfulness as you all are
as
well so if I forget then remind me he
says the to the
Companions
and when we speak about forgetfulness in
Salah there are three types that the
scholars of Islam speak about right so
there are three types of sah that will
happen in a person's
prayer number one you are going to
forget and you're going to leave
something out of the
prayer or you will forget and
accidentally add something on to the
prayer so for example leave something
out instead of making four
for you make three okay so this person
left out one one this
is so this person left something out and
the root of that was forgetfulness the
second
is
forgetfulness by adding something right
so for example a person instead of
making four
for he or she makes five thinking that
it's a fourth thinking that the fifth is
the fourth this here is
a so a person has forgotten and they
have added something to prayer and then
we have a which is mere
confusion right which is mere confusion
some of the scholars refer to this as
and which means that a person is
praying and then they forget how much
they've prayed they don't know if
they've prayed four or three so they're
again in they're not sure if this is the
fourth or the third so what do they do
these are the three types of
forgetfulness that will happen to a
person in his or her prayer now
forgetfulness in its in its Essence is
something that Allah subhah waala has
pardoned us his pardoned the of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam as has
been narrated in that the prophet
s
said he said indeed Allah has pardoned
my nation for
me what they mistakenly do
unintentionally what they forgetfully do
or do not do
and what they are forced to do
under duress these are the three things
that are particular to this
now what does that mean that means
that people in previous nations were
held to account for forget forgetting
something the answer is yes yes and the
reason for that and it is a difference
of opinion but the reason for that is
that for
forgetfulness comes in its
Origins from a lack
of from a lack of focus on something
so if a person forgets something often
times because he or she is not as
concerned with that thing as they should
be
right and so for this reason this is
this is the root of forgetfulness often
times so for this reason Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
refers to the people
who will enter the Hellfire after
having been been warned and after the
message of the prophets and Messengers
have
been explained to
them perfectly pristinely clearly
Allah will refer to them
disobeying as
forgetfulness that they will forget they
have
forgotten right they didn't forget
meaning that they were ignorant of
something after having knowing it they
were forgetful of it meaning that they
were it was unimportant to them it was
inconsequential to them and that is
essentially the root of
forgetfulness often times
and so we see that Allah ascribes
forgetfulness to the sin of Adam
in so he says
subhah Allah subhanahu waala says about
Adam
inah that when Adam ate from the tree he
forgot and we did not find for him any
substantial will to to refrain
from eating from the tree so there was a
lack of will therefore a person
forgets for this reason the prophet
sallallah Ali wasallam prohibited that a
person say I forgot any verse of the
Quran and many scholars view this as
well for the Hadith of the Prophet Sall
alai
wasallam Muslim he said s
he says
s it is a terrible thing for a man to
say I have forgotten such and such verse
of the Quran rather he was made to
forget so when a person says about a
verse that he once knew and due to a
lack of prac practice was made to
forget it he is to not to say I forgot
it he is not to say he is to
say I knew this verse but I was made to
forget it
why the answer is because in admission
of forgetfulness in this way it
articulates necessarily an a lack of
concern
a lack of
diligence a weakening willpower to
remain constantly conscious of the
verses of Allah subhanahu wa
taala and
so after understanding that this does
not mean that the prophet Muhammad s.
wasam forgets because of negligence that
is not what is intended rather this is a
common human issue right and so being
that it is a common human issue everyone
is that is human is predisposed to
forgetfulness just every human
being is predisposed to sinfulness even
though that sinfulness is of different
levels the prophet s. was said
he says all children of Adam are mistak
makers or Sinners people who inherently
will have this but the best of
those Sinners are those who are in
constant repentance to Allah subhanahu
wa taala forgetfulness is something that
every human being is predisposed to and
this is why Allah found it U appropriate
to describe
himself with a very very unique
description on the tongue of
Moses that my Lord neither becomes
confused unaware nor does he forget
subhanahu wa taala so this is something
that is unique to Allah subhanahu wa
taala and
so in order for us to understand now
this is the essence of
forgetfulness in the legislation of
Islam in Salah forgetfulness is these
three types either a person forgets and
adds something a person forgets and
forgets leaves out something or a person
forgets and is
unclear and we'll give that example
again person let's say is making they
are to bake four units of prayer
four okay okay and so when they reach
the third ra they think that it is the
fourth this is
called so the person forgot and they
left out if the person stands up for a
fifth then this person has
forgotten and added a fifth to prayer
and then a person reaches a ra and
they're unsure is this the third or is
this the fourth ra so they are unsure
what should they do and this is what we
are going to be discussing tonight
in and another thing to take into
account before we continue with the
words
of is
that the two the two suud of SE the two
s that the two prostrations that a
person
makes because of
forgetfulness they in themselves are for
obligations they take the place of
obligatory acts not pillars pillars must
be made
up what does that mean well let's take a
dive into
this the actions of prayer the
statements of prayer the
abstaining or what a person abstains
from in prayer they are four types okay
we have
conditions
pillars
obligations sunin things that are
recommended things that are encouraged
but are not absolutely necessary they're
not binding
these are four four
categories okay
conditions are in the correct opinion
eight conditions of
prayer and pillars are 14 pillars of
Prayer in the correct
opinion excuse me I was going to sneeze
there for a second and alhamdulillah
kept it in okay so these are this is
the difference between a condition and a
pillar conditions and pillars are the
same thing except that conditions are
outside of the actual Act of prayer
whilst pillars are part of the integrity
and the actions of prayer so for example
W is a condition actually purification
but we'll say w for Simplicity is a
condition of
prayer whereas standing
or is a pillar of prayer what is the
difference one is outside of prayer and
one is part of prayer itself this is the
only difference between conditions and
pillars there are a couple of others but
this is the main
one the second thing
is obligations
obligations there are a number of
obligations in a very in a very
popular
opinion also in the of
immed there are eight
conditions of pray there are eight oblig
obligations of prayer okay eight
obligations of prayer such as sub
in the first Etc there are a few now
when a person wishes to
make which are these two
additional
suud for forgetfulness any of the three
types we
mentioned if the person is
making for leaving something out
then if it is an
obligation then is
enough but if it is a
pillar then a person must redo that
pillar if it is a condition a person
must redo the prayer
right so what does that mean so for
example let's
say saying sub
in the position saying it at least once
so this is a an
obligation or let's say one that most of
the scholars agree on the first
tah in a in a in a a prayer that has
more than one t so for example the first
in not the last one just before t but
the first one the one after the second
ra this is an
obligation okay and what an obligation
means is that if it is left off on
purpose the prayer is invalid but if it
is forgotten the prayer is still valid
okay so a person is praying they make
the second suud of the
second of
they stand up for the third and they
have forgotten the T that is supposed to
fall in in between those two places this
person has left off an obligation what
do they
do well they make their Salah and then
they make to that's it right if they
leave it off on purpose well I'm kind of
in a bind I'm in a hurry let me just
leave it off on purpose the prayer is
invalid a pillar however
does not have that ruling whether a
person forgets it or leaves it off on
purpose it must be done if they leave it
off on purpose the prayer is invalid if
they forget it they must redo it so
let's say a person
now is praying and leaves off
R right so they go straight from the
standing position to
Su and they forget the r
then they remember what should they do
they should stand up and not count that
ra they should stand up and not count
that ra it did not it did not happen so
if that was their first ra they stand up
from and now this is their
first why
because bowing is a pillar of prayer and
a pillar whether forgotten or not must
be fulfilled in order for the prayer
to be valid
right
now the scholars of Islam all
agree that as far
as is concerned for a person to make
those two s should we make it before or
should we make it after T they all agree
that it is valid before or after
Tas regardless of the mistake made in
prayer if you make it before or after
Tas it's valid the only difference that
they differ on is what is better what is
better and this is what will speak about
here he
says so the prophet s. wasam
stood
up and he had stood up
for the third
ra after only making after making two ra
without so he he's making or he's making
he's supposed to
make excuse me
not he's supposed to
make after the second before he goes up
to the third but he forgot to do that so
he stood straight up from the second to
the third okay so he forgot
to what did he
do
says he
says and what the prophet sallallahu
alai wasallam did in this instance was
he made
suud
before he made T so when he finished the
prayer and he was finished with a the
final T and he was getting ready to make
T he made two s right just two as you
normally would make in prayer this is
called suud the C the prostration of
forgetfulness he did this s. wasam
before he made
T comments on this and says hence what
is taken from this action of his is that
whoever forgets something that is an
obligation and not a pillar whoever
forgets something from Salah that is not
a
pillar then this person when making
would make it
before and also what is to be taken from
this narration that he is speaking about
is
that if an individual
forgets that thing which is not a
pillar
forgets it and starts on another pillar
or starts on another position of prayer
then the person does not go back the
person does not go back what does that
mean so let's
say the same issue here it's the
second of a a fourth
four he forgets
so he stands straight up from the
second to the third forgets T once he
reaches the standing position to pray to
start
with he does not go back into the
sitting
position he does not go back into the
position that is that is done
likewise another thing that happens to
people it does happen often let's say a
person makes one suud and forgets the
second
sujud so they're making Salah they make
they stand up they go to Su and from
that sujud they stand straight up again
right and so they forgot the second suud
what did they do well we understand here
from that the person continues on with
his prayer and as we said before when a
pillar is left out we leave off the
entire right so let's say that was my
first I finished the first sujud I stand
up okay now I'm
making again I forgot oh I forgot to
make the second
sujud that doesn't count this now is my
first ra right or second or third or
fourth whatever position a person might
be
in there is a statement of some of
the who view that if a person is
closer to the position that he forgot
then he goes back and if he's already
closer to the next position then he
continues on what does this mean let's
say again he forgets
the so he's standing up for the third ra
he stands up from the suud straight into
the third ra he's halfway then he
remembers oh I'm supposed to make should
he go back down or not this is where the
scholars differ some of the F
said some of the fuk said if he's closer
to sitting then he sits back
down and if he is closer to standing
then he continues on but there is a
narration in iMed in which the prophet
sallai wasallam was narrated to have
said and it is a narration authenticated
by many scholars of
Hadith that if a
person has not started the
second position then the person goes
back so even if you're almost completely
standing then you and you remember just
before you completely stand then you go
back it doesn't matter which one you're
closer to and that's the soundest
opinion so if a person is
praying he forgets the T he stands up
and just as he's going to put his hands
together and start
reciting he remembers I forgot he sits
back
down and at the end of the prayer he
makes he says
[Silence]
okay
now he says and in another narration the
prophet s.
wasam made t meaning he finished and
concluded
prayer in one of the two afternoon
prayers there are two late Day prayers
there is afternoon which is and then
there is evening which
is both of these prayers are
called because this is the time the time
of it is
meaning end of day
right says it was either he is alluding
here to a difference amongst
the and the the the narrators of Hadith
as to which one it was some mention it
was some mention it
was right but IMI chose that it
was in the narration of Abu Hur and it
is widely known amongst the scholars
of and the scholars of Hadith
ASI which is kind of a kind of an
interesting name to the Hadith there
are certain names there are certain
Hadith which are known by certain names
because of their uniqueness just if
I
sayak right
is a the only
chapter in the Quran in which the
story of
the cow of B is is mentioned so it's
referred to asak well there are
narrations this as well where the
only narration that mentions this
particular story or this particular
person or this particular event or this
particular ruling it starts to have a
name amongst the scholars of Hadith and
this particular narration that I'm
referring to is known
as it is the narration of the man or
the one of two hands I mean it kind of
gets Lost in Translation a little bit
what does that
mean there was a man that was a
companion of the Prophet Sall
wasallam who is known by a nickname
as
and this man was known as the hands man
or the guy with the long hands because
he actually had abnormally long arms or
long hands right and so he would that
this is the only time we find in the
Sunnah the popular Sunnah
that is mentioned and he plays role in
this narration and that is that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam as
according to the narration of alkari
made and after he
made he made from two instead of four he
forgot
two Abu narrates that the prophet
sallallah alai wasam finished prayer
turned around and faced The Companions
and leaned up against some wood that was
in the
Masid
and and he was you could see in his face
as if he was upset about something now
he wasn't
upset but he
felt spiritually he had left
something out of pray prayer but he had
forgotten wasallam
so
asked did prayer change or did you
forget
meaning he said I didn't forget nor was
anything changed in
prayer and he
said he said no you you only prayed two
ra and so he asked others of the
companions they all confirmed yes you he
only prayed two ra and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam stood up
everyone stood up with him they prayed
two more ra right allahar prayed two
more and then he
made then he made
suud then he made taslim again
okay what
happened so let's go over it
again the has it that he was leading the
companions
in either way it's the same thing so he
is leading the companions
in the companions are praying behind him
he made the first ra he made the second
ra he thought that the second was
actually the
fourth when actually it was only the
second how many are supposed to be in
four obviously he just made
two so he made he made Salah upon
himself s what we known
as after this he made then he turned
around and faced the companions as he
would customarily do the companions
then informed him that he forgot
to upon which he stood up he said
allahar and they said allahar with him
and he prayed two
more then he
made then he made
two right one two then he made T again
this is how he did
it
now when we look collectively now we
said we have one narration of him making
the
before that mentioned and we have
another one that mentions where he
made after this narration here and we
said is three types forgetfulness in
prayer
so we have
forgetfulness and adding accidentally
something to prayer or leaving something
out of prayer or completely becoming
confused and forgetting
right the
scholars all agree
that is valid before or after T it
doesn't matter
if you make it before Tas or if you make
it after it is fine okay what they
differ
on
is what is better is it better to make
it before t or after T it's valid either
way but what is
better when we look at all of the body
of the sun of the Prophet sallallahu
alaih wasallam we look at all of the
different things that occurred and and
collectively we notice a pattern what is
the
pattern that if a person leaves
something out of
prayer they
make before meaning in prayer and if a
person adds something to
prayer then what they do is they
make
after okay so now let's look at
this in the first example gives
us he says that the prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam left out the
first he left out the first
[Silence]
so we have the first example where he
forgot something from prayer which was
the first and he made those two
prostrations in prayer before
[Silence]
so we see in the
second example that he Sall alaih
wasallam left off
two from
when he was informed he stood up he made
he made those extra two and then he
made outside of prayer
after now a person may say well hang on
didn't we just say that if a person
leaves something out of prayer that they
should
make they should make
the in inside of prayer we say yes but
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
added something to this
[Silence]
prayer for
so we see here that the prophet sallai
wasall actually added something to
prayer how so when he made the
two and then he made and then he was
informed of the two missing ra he stood
up and made them and then he made T
again is actually a pillar of Prayer
so when he did this he actually added
another pillar which was a tasim again
so really the forgetfulness was adding
that second T therefore he
made
after if I mean this is not extremely
complicated stuff it's not it's not very
complicated it's it's actually rather
simple rather easy it just takes a
little bit of patience for a person to
try to understand and often times what
we do is we
[Silence]
say a person may say well you know I
don't really have to understand this
that much because this is kind of
complicated or intricate a little bit
anyways if anything happens to me I'll
just ask theik well that sounds nice but
that's in reality that's not how it
is you may be a place where there is no
person to ask or you may be somewhere
where the person to ask is doesn't know
what he's talking about or doesn't have
an answer for you it's your
responsibility to learn what it is Allah
has asked of you individually
[Silence]
was
and here in another instance the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam made Salah
and then he made tasim and he left the
Masjid on his way
out one of the companions said you
forgot one ra you actually prayed one ra
short we don't know what it is whether
it was the fourth of a four or the third
of a
three told him you you forgot one so he
went back in the Masid told to make
again and why did he tell B to make well
instead of announcing
[Silence]
saying instead of making an announcement
oh we'd to tell everybody we forgot
one ra please come back so we could pray
look he just told B make the again when
people hear the in the time of the
prophet sallallah
am they know to come and pray and so
they prayed behind him an
additional and so he completed that
prayer sallai wasam this has been
collected by IM Ahmed
[Silence]
he says and he also
made as
five
once right
supposed to be four he actually he
accidentally made five thinking that it
was
four and the companions informed him
that you made five and so he made
two the prostrations of forgetfulness
after
right also he had
made as three he made three instead of
four
and so he went got up and he went into
his home and the people reminded him you
made three instead of four actually
and so he went back out into the Masjid
and he prayed a fourth time and then he
made and then he made and then he made
for the same reason that we mention in
theith
of he says this is all what has been
narrated from the prophet sallallahu
alam's forgetfulness in prayer and it's
only five instances so if you imagine
23 years of prayer and he forgets five
times that's a pretty good record right
that is extremely extremely extremely
rare
now now just as a kind of
[Silence]
recap
when Subhan Allah
Subhan Allah Subhan Allah
[Silence]
huh for
IM
[Silence]
fore for
and so if the Imam were to make a
mistake and add a
ra and a person is sure that the Imam is
adding a raak that they would not add
one with him they would remaining in the
sitting position and wait for the Imam
to
finish and likewise if the IM forgets a
and they are positive that the IM forgot
a then they would stand up for the final
and they would pray it alone just as
somebody who was
mistakenly who had come in
late and this is a difference that a lot
of people don't understand with regards
to the difference between the Salah of
the IM and the
[Silence]
sub
for to
toim
[Silence]
for
for for
[Silence]
next week inshallah we will continue